[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute mein
leckeres toilette rezept das ist nicht
das was ich schon auch mal mit kanada
online ab ich hatte vor jahren schon mal
eins gemacht das war erst auf die
türkische art angelehnt heute machen wir
die albanische art trilogie sagt manja
tritscher also drei milchsorten viele
sagen man müsste dann auch zeigen welche
cetera benutzen ich mache es auf meine
art und ich schwöre es euch meine
toilette egal wer sie probiert hat jeder
ist durchgedreht und auch ihr bzw
alle die sich mein kochbuch besorgt
haben ich verlinke euch hier unten in
die infobox da habe ich das rezept
nämlich veröffentlicht und das rezept so
wie es hier steht gibt es hat noch gar
nicht auf einem kanal und ich werde es
heute mit euch machen und die
zubereitung ist sehr einfach und
ernsthaft jeder der es probiert hat auch
leute die ich zu besuch hatte diesen
durchgedreht weil so soft und lecker
schmeckt uns ganz kurz jetzt kurz ja
trilogie ja kommt eigentlich aus
südamerika oder einiger südamerika
gemacht jetzt so schnell wiederkommen
also ich bin ehrlich ich bin einfach nur
froh dass es so unfassbar lecker ist und
dass ich das für mich perfekte rezept
also nochmals zu klatschen und gittis
reduziert ich mach jetzt gießt relaxe
albanisch angehaucht also hat auch zu
diskutieren ihr könnt dann diskutieren
das ehrliche art bringt aber du weißt ja
das ist falsch
ja aber das ist der rezepte da rezepte
kann man immer variieren ich habe mir
überlegt weil ich auch im buch zum
beispiel eine auflaufform die hier bin
ist das ist perfekt für acht ordentlich
große portionen und da habe ich mir
gedacht ich nehme es heute dass hier
auch im video aber falls ihr ihn mit
großer familie habt oder vier besuch
bekommt werde ich euch auch so eine
klassische große eckige auflaufform da
die maße die habe ich mir auch als also
ich hab mal als ausgerechnet ich habe
mir das alles aufgeschrieben wie man
dann die zutaten multiplizieren muss und
die das rechne ich für euch auf der
gartenarbeit die schreibe ich euch unten
in die in bonn
genauso wie alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben und ich würd sagen haben
statt mit direkt noch los geht's als
erstes werden jetzt die eier getrennt
das mache ich ganz vorsichtig und ganz
wichtig ist es darf nichts wirklich gar
nichts vom gelb in die eismasse aber
erstmal zur seite legen und ich war
schon mal kurz die hände ich habe hier
alles was im moment als erstes schlagen
wir jetzt das eiweiß auf das ist wichtig
dass nicht nur das eiweiß halt sauber
getrennt ist sondern dass auch wirklich
die schüsse sauber und fettfrei ist da
gebe ich jetzt auch schon direkt eine
gute prise salz mit rein und dann
schlage ich das auf ca erst mal 30
sekunden cea erst mal 30
auch erst mal 30 sekunden machen damit
es richtig schön dick cremig wird und
dann kommt zucker dazu und wird noch
eine weitere minute komplett unter
wasser aufgeschlagen
[Musik]
so fertigen bmw masse rühren wir dann
ganz kurz das eigelb unter also wirklich
nur so gerade 58 sekunden bis er sich
verbunden hat und die massen sagt auch
nicht einsieht richtig schön fluffig und
das rezept ist wirklich anfänger
geeignet und geht auch ganz ganz schnell
denn den ofen habe ich auch schon
vorgeheizt da sage ich euch gleich die
backzeit ich habe jetzt hier noch ganz
normales mehl und backpulver und ich
werde das vorab ganz kurz miteinander
verrühren bin nervös heute so nervös war
gleich kommt noch eine ganz besondere
nachricht da müsst einfach dran beim bis
zum ende und da gebe ich jetzt diese
trockenen zutaten einmal durch mein
liebstes jetzt schon mal komplett rhein
geben aber ich drücke nur ein paar mal
hebt das unter und dann mache ich das
wirklich so in zwei bis drei schritten
mit ganz viel liebe ihr kennst dich
anders mit einem teig schaber und dann
richtig schön von außen nach innen
streichen
[Musik]
würde tag ist fertig aber alles schön
und geduldig untergehoben und jetzt
nehmen wir uns unsere backform einen bug
raum funktioniert an der stelle leider
nicht weil wir haben gleich diese milch
trinke und es schwimmt erst mal in
dieser milch trinke und dann braucht es
zeit dass ganz einzuziehen
daher wird zwar im bug rahmen
untendrunter rauslaufen und das möchten
wir unbedingt vermeiden weshalb hier auf
jeden fall eine auflaufform bestens
geeignet ist am pc auf dem boden ein
backpapier gelegt die seiten da hab ich
nichts dran dass wir doch nicht gefettet
generell brauchst gar nicht gefährdet
werden und jetzt fühlen wir den teig ein
und streichen dem noch etwas glatt aber
[Musik]
auf jeden fall den backofen schon mal
vorgehalten 180 grad ober und unterhitze
ich glaube es dann 5 20 minuten alles
kann ich mir nie mehr so viele bakterien
gucke ich noch mal schnell bei 25
minuten doch habe ich noch richtig
gemerkt also 15 minuten wieder gebacken
und dann machen wir in der zwischenzeit
auch schon mal mit dem milchpreis zweite
folge von yahoo gute idee wäre es dafür
schreibt so unten rein und ich sprechen
sagen in dem backhaus geschaffen
du darfst einen abend lang gucken was du
willst auf dem fernseher so wie immer
[Musik]
der boden ist schon mal fertig ist ganz
frisch aus dem backofen ich werde jetzt
aber für fünf minuten zur seite legen
der dorfpfarrer auch nicht auskühlen wir
machen wenn ich direkt weiter in der
zwischenzeit früher ich jetzt schon mal
drei zutaten miteinander die wir gleich
darüber gießen und zwar ist das einmal
mehr
dann habe ich noch etwas sahne ich will
auf die samen nicht verzichten weil die
gibt es noch einen ganz anderen
geschmack und dann kommt noch gezuckerte
kondensmilch dazu oder vor ruhig das
einfach und da kommt jetzt noch kein
extra zucker auch im teig überlegt mal
leute ich habe im gesamten teig nur 50
gramm zucker auf acht stücke also das
ist fast nichts
und hier gebe ich auch keinen zucker
mehr dazu weil die gezuckerte
kondensmilch reicht mir da an süßes und
allgemein ist es auch kein upps kein
kuchen der so ultra süß ist also gar
nicht eigentlich die ist einfach nicht
daran denke macht das doch ist genau
karamell macht noch mal so richtig schön
abschluss und das ist auch wo einen
kuchen da könnte man locker zwei stücke
verdrücken oder es ist soweit
ja
[Musik]
jetzt wird der lauwarme kuchen einmal
aus der form gestürzt dafür müssen wir
bei die ränder vorab einmal lösen ich
nehme dafür meine winkel palette weil
ich einfach so schön flach ist ihr könnt
jetzt auch ein buttermesser nehmen und
dann einfach nur stürzen und umgedreht
wieder zurück in die auflaufform link
warum machen wir das es ist super
wichtig das ist wichtig weil man die
offenen poren quasi oben hat und das die
ganze flüssigkeit tausendmal besser
einsaugt als wenn wir das jetzt ganz
normal in der form last und dann so ein
schlecht ich mache gern trotzdem so dass
sich zusätzlich noch mal mit meinem
schaschlikspieß ein paarmal einstiche
also einfach nur aus sicherheitsgründen
aber eigentlich habt ihr die offenen
poren ja schon oben und können jetzt
diesen ganzen milch kurs darüber gießen
ist mag ich am anfang viel zu viel
vorkommen aber vertraut mir leute das
ist so ganz genau richtig
[Musik]
so hier sieht man noch überall die milch
die wird jetzt aber komplett einziehen
also gibt dem ganzen am besten so 20
minuten und dann machen wir den
abschluss ferse und jetzt kommt die
karamell schicht das ist so das
wichtigste antrieb und da habe ich mir
ja gedanken gemacht okay wie ist das
eigentlich karamell selbst herstellen
funktioniert erkläre ich euch auch ganz
oft in videos aber es ist so eine kleine
königsdisziplin vor allem für diejenigen
die es halt selten machen oder viele
verzweifeln daran weiterhin verbrennt
oder das endergebnis einfach bitter
schmeckt wir haben eine triplette soße
entwickelt oder bin ich ganz stolz drauf
weil das ist halt nicht diese karamell
sind die man aus dem einzelhandel kennt
da gibt es natürlich schon ganz viele
das ist so diese typisch albanische art
die comdirect quasi aus der tube man
kann hier einfach ich ist immer noch so
ein sicherheitssiegel das nehme ich
jetzt auch und spritzt sich quasi
einfach meine tree lecce so sind direkt
aus der tube auf mein kuchen und ich
muss vorher nicht erwärmen oder so und
die konsistenz ist halt auch ganz anders
und ich liebe es einfach ich werde euch
hier unten in die infobox verlinken also
die entwicklung hat monate gedauert ich
glaube ich habe es schon irgendwann vor
acht monaten ein mit tesa dass er da
dran sind jetzt ist sie endlich da und
von der konsistenz her und vom geschmack
her ist sie einfach perfekt und ich
wollte halt auch extra so eine
riesengroße tore machen und nicht nur so
eine kleine damit kommt ihr wenn ihr das
jetzt in dieser form macht ich glaube so
drei bis vier mal aus und auch in seiner
ganz großen auflaufform könnt ihr das
mindestens zwei mal benutzen und ich
fange jetzt einfach mal an in dem ich ja
ok die akkus wieder aufgeladen und ich
werde jetzt einfach mal die soße quasi
auf die oberfläche drauf pumpen also man
muss halt wirklich nur so ganz leicht
die tube andrücken und dann fließt das
auch wie von alleine ich hatte mich nur
noch mal in meiner winkel palette so ein
bisschen glatt streichen
man sieht schon man sieht halt schon
dass es auch durchsichtig ist das halt
wirklich auf albanischer art
[Musik]
eigentlich muss man die gar nicht mehr
verstreichen so und eigentlich ist es ja
jetzt schon fertig ich mag es immer wenn
man noch diese typischen weißen
schokoladen streifen drauf gibt und ich
denke man sieht jetzt schon dass es halt
wirklich keine typische karamellsoße und
so wie sie hier ist so bekommt man die
zu hause auch gar nicht in der
zusammensetzung zu hause hat man diese
klassische karamellsoße schießt dann
genau das wollte stefan dunkl und so ein
bisschen dickflüssiger und so ist die
konsistent die bekommt man halt wirklich
zu hause nicht hin und daher habe ich
mir dieses fertige produkt überlegt ich
finde es super innovativ das gibt es
auch so in deutschland noch gar nicht
also so aus der tube
das macht nicht super happy ich hoffe
euch macht auch hertie vielen ist auch
schon zu hause
letztens damit als kaffee gemacht zwar
auch sehr lecker also hilft auch für
andere sachen benutzen ist muss es
wissen denn selbst massiv genau so und
ich habe jetzt hier weiße schokolade
geschmolzen einfach in heißem wasser ich
habe da ein bisschen kokosöl dazu
gegeben damit dann auch noch mal schön
ja ein bisschen schön weich ist und
nicht so knackt und jetzt machen wir
folgendes einfach streifen
[Musik]
quasi als vorhut aus und man denkt so
hör dir den kuchen versorgt aber nein
einfach mit seinem stück spezifische
muster genau das typische muster ich
mach's zwischendurch immer sauber
und fertig ist unser leckeres tree lecce
ich liebe es ich liebe das rezept das
ist so wie mit dem zwar bastian
cheesecake also die beiden stehen für
mich auf der gleichen stufe und in san
sebastian schiek habe ich eine zeitlang
in jedes wochenende gemacht und das habe
ich kraft mit mit diesem rezept also
probiert es unbedingt aus ich würde mir
von herzen wünschen dass er mir feedback
und in die kommentare schreiben nicht
nur zum rezept sondern auch zu meiner
toilette soße und ansonsten ja was soll
ich sagen leute habt viel freude beim
nachmachen und abonniert main kanal
komplett kostenlos damit ihr nehmt euch
genialen dinge auch nicht mehr verpasst
und dann sehen wir uns ganz beim
nächsten video cherokee
[Musik]
ich dachte der will ich dass wir heute
den text einfach ausfallen lassen hallo
diesen tollen rezepte sagt später folgen
okay ist einen tag später aber muss noch
die entsehen machen und bekommt ihr da
auch gut durchziehen
also ich muss sagen die charaktere mich
so lecker schmecken wir sonst gar nicht
verkaufen also schmeckt das ja ich weiß
ja wie lecker schmeckte klären ist auch
ein kochbuch von soft das ist so dass
das gericht ein vorschlag ist ist weg
weil es so weit jetzt hier können wir
doch ganz gut sehen weiß ich was ich
einmal prüfen ende gucken ich finde der
ist chemisch welt magen ich weiß auch
gar nicht wie es ist somit kalorien
technisch oder so an kalorien technik
werden wir rausfinden erstens habe ich
von meinem buch ausgerechnet und heinz
frei bis ihr euch immer unten in die
video beschreibung das ist jetzt neu
seit ein paar wochen und monaten dass
wir immer die nährwertangaben mit dazu
schreiben die es gefährlich wecker leute
fühlt sich damals schwer eine schlichte
volk das heißt im endeffekt doch jetzt
wird richtig sagt also ganz ehrlich ich
es locker noch ein zweiter joker also
was lernen wir daraus relaxe ist ein
mast bark meisterhaft macht unbedingt
nach kommt zurück zu diesem video und
wenn es euch gefallen hat hinterlasst
einen leib und ein abo und 1 kommentar
wie es euch geschmeckt hat und bestellt
irgendwas so was war so eine tube mehr
so eine braune schuhe
ja nein leute wenn ihr euch drauf bock
habt müsst ihr das damit essen ja es ist
aber so weißt du dass es schwieriger ist
weit über die krawalle auch selbst wenn
du das hinbekommt heißt das nicht dass
das zweite auch in birkungen hier kann
es vom dritten auch er bekommt religious
so von mir ist sehr ergiebig das heißt
ihr könntet das ganze hier in dieser
form vier mal machen 4 x 24 x also ich
wünsche euch noch einen wunderschönen
tag und bis zum nächsten mal auf meinen
kanal hast du jetzt so gemacht hast du
nicht mein thema der reden wo kann
am 8 okay es ist mir eine clutch oder so
erstmalig gibt sam 20 fach kindergarten
gerade im kinder gehabt - nachmachen so
schlimm
[Musik]